So how many are still alive?
Not eaten is still alive.
She's not sure.
New audio
of a recorded phone
conversation obtained by CNN
shows the acting Yuval,
the police
chief, was directly told
that children were trapped with a gunman
and needed rescue, a malfunction
with an air
and still he failed to take direct action
to save them.
He's in the class.
CNN has pieced together
multiple body cameras
and new security footage
from inside the school hallway,
along with this, never
before heard phone call
to show how a failure of leadership
allowed 77 minutes
to tick by before
police killed the gunman.
Acting Yuval
de Police Chief
Mariano Fargas
was among the first police officers
to enter Rob Elementary on May 24th.
The chief of the Arvada
police was on vacation,
which left
Parks in charge of the city police.
Parks arrives at 11:36 a.m.
just 3 minutes after the gunman
fires his first shots and
his officers run in ahead
of him
and make an initial attempt
to breach the classroom.
They quickly retreat
when shots are fired in their direction.
CNN has chosen
to mute the sound of those gunshots.
My breathing
probably roughly 5 minutes later
you've all day school.
District Police Officer Ruben Ruiz,
whose wife is a teacher
at Rob
Elementary, delivers critical information
to targets.
The shooter is located
inside his wife's classroom.
Cruz and my wife, Miss
PA guess, who was suspended
by the city of Uvalde
in July and placed on paid leave
while they investigate his role
as a commanding officer
during the shooting, is walking
in and out of the hallway,
taking cover next to a wall.
Failing to organize a response.
Even when Ruben Ruiz barrels back
into the hallway
telling his colleagues
that his wife,
Eva Morales,
called him from inside the room
and says she's dying.
That's Rubin Ruiz, Rubin Rubin.
She says the shotgun
is not the book.
It's its targets.
The acting chief
who comes and removes
Ruiz from the hallway.
I don't know if Yahoo!
Might have As time goes by,
the police on the scene
can be heard looking to pardus
asking him for direction.
They want to know what the plan is.
Park is
tells them
he's waiting on the Texas
Department of Public Safety.
Are we just waiting for more Tiger Woods
or somebody in there to come in
at 12, 10 p.m.
nearly 30 minutes after police
first arrived.
Ten year old Chloe Torres,
a fourth grader,
trapped inside the room
with the gunman,
is on the phone with a 911 dispatcher.
I'm in a classroom
window.
21 year. 12,
12, one 12 year.
Chloe 23.
There's a lot of dead body.
CNN obtained
that call and published it
with the approval of her parents.
When the dispatcher radios
the information to the officers, parks
and other police on scene
are immediately informed is
is in the room. So
have to have it
for the victims
child call 9114 American Indian Registry
that you could show
the rooms full of victims
local parties who didn't have a radio
with him.
Takes one from a detective
and enters the hallway.
He tells the men inside the child
just call it that have victims in there
but then park it steps back.
2 minutes later,
he walks out of the hallway
and places a phone call
directly to the oval.
The dispatcher.
CNN has obtained this call.
Okay.
In the car,
if you got here from the front,
the one of the students
or what if they say
Okay, Chloe, it's going to be Chloe.
She says No one school.
I'm not going to one 12
students at a time.
This time.
It was tragic.
So how many are still alive?
Not assume you're still alive.
She's not sure how many more
and she's not sure how or actually feel.
But we're still okay.
Okay.
The recorded phone call proves
for the first time
that a senior officer at the scene
was direct
only made aware of the horrors happening
inside the classroom.
Porter Goss walks back in the hallway
one more time.
She called me on one 96 a few seconds
later, the acting police chief
turns his back and walks out
in the doorway.
Parks can be seen talking
to the Texas Ranger Christopher Ryan.
Kendall, who, as CNN
has previously reported,
is currently suspended
and under investigation
for failing
to organize a response that day.
But Park is doesn't appear to tell him
about the nine
when one information he received.
CNN has learned from sources familiar
with the investigation
that a number of law enforcement
officials on scene,
including high ranking officers
with the Texas
Department of Public Safety,
say they did not know about the 911 call.
A few minutes later at 12:20 p.m.
park as can be seen walking away
from the school
away from the hallway
where dozens of officers
from several law enforcement
agencies remain debating, at times
confused and seemingly uncertain
about what to do.
They wouldn't breach the classroom for
another 30 minutes.
CNN analysis of a new
never before
made public angle of the hallway
security camera shows
that park has never stepped foot back
inside this hallway and filled up
in interviews with investigators
obtained by CNN.
Parga says he didn't believe
he was in charge
and his officers
from the Nevada
City Police
were there
only to assist the school police
until the Texas Department
of Public
Safety took over
the Texas
Department of Public Safety,
which placed
seven of its officers
who were at the scene
under further investigation.
Labeled Uvalde School
Police Chief Pete
Arradondo as the on scene commander,
Arradondo, who was fired
in August, maintains
he wasn't in charge either.
We get him out.
CNN reached Park by phone.
He said, quote,
He would love to defend himself,
but he's been told
not to speak to the media,
adding, quote, It's
not that we're afraid
because there's nothing to be afraid of.
We did what we could.
But the thing is that
we've been told that we can't.
In interviews with Texas Rangers.
He was asked
why officers didn't
force their way into the classroom sooner
as active shooter training
clearly indicates.
The room was extremely dark
and we didn't know where he was
or the kids were standing
there were by him
or not knowing what was behind the doors.
Park is didn't
tell the investigators
about his direct call
with the dispatcher and claimed
he didn't remember
hearing radio traffic
about the 911 calls.
We knew we as
we had
heard all the shots,
but we don't know whether
there were kids in there.
It's a line at your office
that we no idea.
But Park just did know.
He knew
Ruben Ruiz,
his wife, called
and said she was inside dying
and he knew a child called nine
when one
and said she was in room
one 12 surrounded by victims
as the acting.
Uvalde police chief, Mariano
Parks was a commanding officer on scene
and could have done something about it.